after a performance at the nightclub bar
120 on the 27th of September he was
arrested in Brisbane and extradited to
Perth on
Wednesday Islam net is raising funds to
establish a mjid and Community Center in
Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be AAR for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will be reaping the reward
click the link and donate what you
canum brothers and sisters and dear
friends uh I'm here with Sabor how you
doing how you doing good in don't forget
to subscribe to saor channel in brother
sisters and sign up to his course zombie
scrolling we're going to put the link
there in Sister check that out it's for
those zombies like me who are scrolling
like a crackhead uh but something very
bizarre today's topic is obviously young
Philly and what's happened to him we're
going to react to some videos but
something so bizarre happened to me
today I want to share it like cuz I
found it very very very weird it was it
was it was shocking I'm going to sh that
bit later but let's watch this in and
just see what the allegations are and
let's talk about how Islam deals with
these problems because we say Islam
deals when it comes to the sexualization
um of you know Society um how women are
sexualized Islam deals with this on a
micro level to a macro level we're going
to come but let's just watch this video
and then popular UK rapper and YouTuber
Yung Philly has been arrested on rape
and assault charges in Australia the
internet personality born Andres Felipe
Valencia bar OS 29 appeared in Perth
magistrates court on Thursday charged
with three counts of assault occasioning
bodily harm and four counts of sex
sexual penetration without consent he
has also been charged with one count of
impeding another person's breathing or
circulation by applying pressure to the
neck Mr bentos is currently on tour in
Australia the alleged assault of a woman
in her 20s took place on the 28th of
September in a Perth hotel room after a
performance at the nightclub bar 120 on
the 27th of September he was arrested in
Brisbane and extradited to Perth on
Wednesday he remains in custody okay so
what do you mean out that bro I mean the
first thing is from an Islamic
perspective look at the lifestyle that a
person is living and whether that's
going to open up a person to be in
positions such as these positions that
we're talking about right now you're
performing at nightclubs or you're
performing or whatever you're
intermingling with women and we cannot
at this moment say whether he's guilty
or he's not guilty the police are doing
their job the courts are doing their job
the main thing is what is the Heen istic
Lifestyle the materialistic lifestyle
this objectification that people like
him are involved in cuz look when you're
on the YouTube uh scrolling randomly you
are going to come across videos of
people like him you know they've got
this thing about you know grading women
and women are grading them and all this
type of this hedonistic very this
degrading way that women are looked at
so you know that's the first thing to to
point out I'm not saying that you know
he's guilty or he's not guilty but I'm
saying just overall lifestyle is not
acceptable exactly you know the reason
why one of the pandemics we have is the
sickness of beauty because all these
women are being judged by and that's
what you look at like I just ask a real
simple question why is it that every
woman 99% of women have the cleavages
out and they are dressed up in some some
way of an inappropriate way if if if
there's Freedom of Choice you will see a
different variety of people they dress
in different ways majority of the girls
that go clubbing or partying they all
dress in a certain way what's happened
about my choice it's not cuz it's a
manufacturing consent it's you think
you're under the delusion read the book
Beauty sck it talks about a woman who
felt so ugly about herself because of
the beauty industry and PE pressure and
the opposite gender that she thought
that in order to valuate herself was to
go and sleep with men and then the same
book talks about a woman girls young
girls who are having yoger every 4 hours
so they don't pass out because they they
are conscious about their body this all
because of the sick culture that we have
and that's why Islam deals with these
problems on a micro level to macro level
from micro level we are told as men in
the Quran what tell the believer men to
do what lower the Gaz lower the Gaze
which means that we cannot sexually
objectify a woman not based on how she's
dressed does Allah say in the Quran
lower your gaze to the woman in no lower
your gaze period it doesn't matter if
you're just a bikini Min skirt
irrelevant not only that look at the
fact that Allah is not telling you and
the prophet peace be upon Him is not
telling you marry a Woman based upon her
beauty we are told to marry based upon
The Virtuous religious values that they
have and the thing is that's valuing of
women feminism doesn't value women red
pill doesn't value women this certainly
doesn't and look you know when I hear
about stuff like this look stuff like
this happens all the time it happened
with Lawrence Krauss the guy that
debated Hamza right you know talking
about women's rights and what ends up
happening seual all this type of stuff
so the fact is all of these allegations
keep coming out cuz people are putting
are being put into situations like that
this happened recently with another UFC
fighter as well many people so the the
fact is you said this earlier on right
you had that interaction with
that yeah exactly and she wanted to
shake your
hand I don't and this is very ironic
because you know when it comes to
grooming gang issues I'm not even
allowed to touch your hand and you're
telling me as Muslims we can drug
kidnap alcohol drugs kind of and rap
what are you talking about I spoke to
her and then the whole me movement thing
came out and now in certain workplace in
certain organizations corporations if a
man and woman is alone in a room the
door has to be open and his interaction
with her he can't be touching her again
like this like this there's a whole
discussion of what is comfortable what
does Islam say prevention is better than
cure you're coming back to what Islam
teaches yeah exactly you know so funny
um on the London Underground you'll find
uh signs right which will say staring is
basically sexual uh could be sexual
something right anything that Islam has
been prohibiting people from in terms of
male female interaction people have
realized actually this makes sense but
you know what liberalism doesn't allow
it Hedonism doesn't allow it they still
want women to be objectified they still
want only fans accounts to be opened
they want women to you know I was
watching this video the other day and
there's this woman and somebody some
there's this guy who's just going around
interviewing women and then This Woman's
like yeah I had an only fans account
made a couple hundred pound it's like
everywhere this objectification
everywhere this pressure and like you
said I love what you said there if it's
Freedom of Choice you'll find a variety
some are covered some are not covered
some are here but why is everyone going
towards the the furnace because that is
manufacturing consent that's what
Society tells you you don't have value
unless you have this and what happens
when that same woman hits the big three
right okay I need to get BOTOX I need to
get cuz that's it they they've lost
their thing according to those standards
and they talk about Freedom you are not
free at all and these are there was also
College University students who were
going working in strip clubs to pay for
their tuition Fe okay this was happening
in in in the Western World the point I'm
seeing is is the following guys is that
Islam deals with the prevention rather
than cure now coming back to your
thinking okay what's has got to with the
whole F situation the point is this a
man and a woman should never be in a
proximity in that situation you might
find find this bizarre but you are
paying the consequences of men and women
interactions because you don't have
those preventions rather better than
cure you're opening the doors to all of
this stuff and all kind of manness is
happening yes okay this doesn't justify
any man to force himself on a woman the
point we're seeing is that is the
extreme level Islam deals with it to a
point where it shouldn't even come near
that at all it's not about consent or
consent it shouldn't even come to that
level and just to touch him on because
I've told you guys what happened today
something really bizarre happened bro is
that just give some disclaimers I'm not
a pier I'm nobody asking it's just I
found it very weird today I woke up I
don't know from where I had this idea
like not idea this thought came to my
mind thing cuz we were in the D in it if
if I had a friend who was not a Muslim I
would get upset so in my head it popped
into my head randomly I didn't know
anything about this that was it young
Philly young FY died and I was putting
my shoes myself in chunks of shoes and
thinking Subhan Allah like he'll be
upset and think you know what I wish he
died as a Believer and I went to a
meeting with a team and they were like
oh you know a couple of hours later and
they were like did you hear what
happened to Young Philly and in my head
when I heard that at first I was like
who's young Philly cuz I don't know
their names properly so I was think are
they talking about the same person I was
like are you talking about chun's friend
they were like yeah I was like nah bro I
was like I thought he he died and in my
head I was thinking n that's yeah and
they were like no no like he didn't die
like what happened he's like you got
accused with this and I found it very
bizar I know there's some explanation
like scientif about just so bizarre that
came to my mind and I just found it
really odd I wonder what you know you
told me this you told me this in the
office yeah and I said to you look
Rupert sheldrick has the idea of the
extended mind that your mind your
Consciousness goes out in the world and
interacts the fact is yeah there are
look there's something more to this
world in just the material matter yeah
and this look something like that what's
what's the chances of
that I just find it so bizarre because
look I imagine him dead like I thought
he died that's what I came I don't know
if it was a dream I don't came to mind
but it was we weren't even planning on
making a reaction video to this until
until I started playing it you prayed
start playing video said bro this thing
so just to end the video Ali what's the
main message look when it comes to
someone like young Philly who many many
people are looking up to now and they're
following the news right now they're
thinking did he do it did he not do it
the question is not whether he did it or
not that's a separate question that's
we're going to find out to the root the
root of the cause there's evil happening
even before this exactly that's what the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
when a man and a woman is alone the
third is Shan okay this is the reason
Reon why we have strict protocols when
it comes to interaction with men and
women of course we have another extreme
in Islam which is women are yeah if you
see the if you see a woman you jump out
the window like she's not a human being
no yeah yeah that's Other Extreme I know
I know the brothers who saying if I go
in a lift and there's a sister I would
not go in that lift yeah yeah Ai and
it's a lift and go to Second people go
to extremes where they treat women as if
they're eny like oh my gosh you know run
away no a they're human beings the
sahaba spoke the individuals you know
what I'm trying to say look so you know
you don't want to be the lifting of the
woman privately no of course but I'm
talking about but what what happens is
like you said people take it to an
extreme where it's like oh we we'll take
it to such an extreme that even the
sahaba didn't exactly were balanced EXA
exactly exactly and it's very bizarre
because a lot of brothers like they
would rather if if it was a non-muslim
woman they would go in that lift you
should it shouldn't go either way no no
no no the point is this I'm talking
about let's not let's not say one woman
let's suppose there's two free if
there's two free sisters like they'll be
like if there was kufar woman like for
example they'll have no issue but for
some reason I don't know I just find it
a little bit odd it's like
hypersexualization from another way it's
like they think any kind of interaction
with woman it's like a no go bro there
Islam is a fine balance Islam is a
balance where you have an interaction
with modesty and ha do you get what I'm
trying to say but yeah I mean it's young
Philly would never to end this video
young Philly would never be in a
situation like this if those Islamic
principles were exposed and the problem
is nowadays this is normalized I mean
look look he's not the first he's not
the last it's been happening with UFC
fighters it's been happening with people
from academics to school teachers or
whatever all these things things just
keep coming out coming out coming out
and do you know what I see Al over the
next couple of years it's just going to
go an exponential curve it me you even
more even more yeah and the solution is
Islam and um anyways like I said we're
not going to comment on if he was guilty
or not guilty but Islam is your solution
again it's just the Western system it
just fails again and again and again
come back to your roots come back to
where you belong which is Islam and deal
with these matters prevention rather
than cure not drink alcohol we deal with
rehab get into a gambling addiction on
the verge of killing yourself then no
don't go there and yeah that's it that's
all we want to say
in the prophet sallu alhi wasallam said
whoever builds a m for the sake of Allah
subhana wa tala Allah will build for him
a similar house in jenah on that day
where Allah subhana tala tells us that
our books will be given and every little
atom weight of Good Deed you've done
will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you for me yes yes what
did I do you allowed people to pray you
built a Masjid I never had the money to
build a Masjid oh Allah you helped you
gave towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you've built it donate
now guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra Rewards
[Music]